a metro sergeant is sharing his  experience with covet 19 in hopes  that others will take the virus  seriously sergeant tom jenkins admits he  thought  it was a joke at the start of the  pandemic but details his real-life fight  after falling ill i know what it's like  to  to be sitting in a hospital and uh  it feels like somebody put a bag around  your head and duct taped to your neck  where you can't breathe covet is not a  joke  i'm here to tell you uh it almost took  me off this planet  in a video produced by the department  sergeant jenkins says he tested positive  last month  and spent more than a week in the  hospital he was one of five on his team  that tested positive  the sergeant is not vaccinated but says  he will get the shot when he is healthy  enough  and encourages others to do the same